well polish police say the body of a
syrian man has been found near the
border with belarus at least 11 people
have now died in the humanitarian crisis
on the polish belarusian border on
friday turkeys stopped citizens of iraq
syria and yemen from flying to belarus
from its territory
thousands of people are camped out on
the berlin russian side of the border in
freezing conditions trying to cross into
bordering eu
member states like poland poland has
deployed its army to stop them and set
up an exclusion zone that aid workers
and journalists are barred from entering
desperate
migrants scramble for aid packs
containing blankets and winter clothing
they move along belarus's border with
poland for long days and nights seeking
a path into the eu
their assembling in this area has
reinforced the diplomatic and physical
divide between the two countries
both sides accuse each other of using
the migrants to score points
some migrants like this iraqi kurdish
family eventually make it across
we stayed for four nights in that forest
during that period we tried to cross six
times until we succeeded and entered
poland
now snooty poland
but they ended up in the hands of the
authorities on that side and were soon
deported
the polish migrants rights organization
ottelene foundation is lodging a
complaint against poland at the
international criminal court for these
forced returns
poland alongside international community
has a responsibility to protect people
from those crimes and
allow them to ask for
protection
and
and respond to this crisis pushing
people back to the belarus
where it's extremely dangerous and
violence
is not
the thing that is
that the democratic country should do
and it's a violation of international
law
as the political standoff continues more
migrants are arriving in the border area
and they are growing concerns about
their fate as a brutal winter sets in
now dw correspondent marina strauss has
just returned from the border between
poland and belarus and joins us for more
hi good to see you marina now clearly
there are attempts to limit the number
of migrants reaching belarus but what
about those already in the country and
those at the border region trying to
cross into poland
many migrants and refugees are still
stuck at the border in belarus that's
what you said already but some or also
made it through the barbed wire fences
through to to poland and uh we cannot
really verify what's going on directly
at the border with poland because you
mentioned that there's this exclusion
zone
journalists and also age workers are not
allowed to enter there but just to
describe a little bit what it looks like
there it's like vast forests there's
swamps there's wild animals for example
wolves it's freezing cold especially at
night in this region so you can only
imagine what it must be like for the
people who are like trying to find their
way there and i am also in touch with a
local activists on the ground and they
just told us that yesterday night they
found 10 people
among them children in a very bad
condition outside the exclusion zone and
there are certainly more people in these
forests are looking for for help looking
for a way out of there
now marina polish authorities have
ramped up their efforts to keep migrants
out of the country what obligations do
poland and the european union have
though
for polish or for poland or at least the
polish government it's quite clear that
their obligation is to protect the
border that's also what the spokeswoman
of the border guards
told us um two days ago
and they say we have to protect our
border we have to protect the eu's
external border and the eu actually says
we don't want to bow to the pressure of
belarus here so usually eu law says that
once a person wants a refugee enters eu
territory wherever it is maybe in poland
spain italy um the person has the right
to apply for asylum so these people who
come to poland should have the right to
apply for asylum but that doesn't
actually always happen because poland
changed its laws and now it's
practically legal to push back these
people to belarus and also ngos tell us
this is happening on a regular basis
alright ritw's marina strauss thanks for
your reporting